I mean what else do you want you got
Bill Byrne a Batman shirt you know in
this hotel shirt I got it and I can't
tell you how many Nerds stopped me on
the street dude did you see the last one
I know it's unbelie I thought he was
gonna die thank God he didn't right
[Applause]
you know what I like about Batman I like
Batman because he's a he's mortal
I don't I don't like Batman
and I don't like [__] Spider-Man and
it's a shame that they never made the
real superhero the [__] gangster Bill
who's the best super I mean we know who
it is wait wait wait back up you just
named my two favorite you don't like
Batman or Superman no no Spider-Man no
the the most the the best superhero ever
they [__] up every one of his movies
but he's the [__] in my opinion he's
the goat the [__] Man of Steel dude
Superman [__] Superman
they ever since Christopher Reeves rest
his soul they've never made it who's
ever debated that Jesus Christ but I
swear to God you are doing an Olive
Garden Cheesecake Factory
Nike uh of course you like Superman
who's what do you mean ever a left turn
you know I like the first one of them
all
well he's the best one and they don't
make his movies good they keep making
this stupid [__] movie not the best
one I think he's the best he's my
favorite and I think some glasses and he
Parts his hair the other way and nobody
can figure out it's him only well that's
stupid but nothing could kill him other
than Kryptonite dude
and he's [__] and anything
what in the in the comics in the early
90s they killed Superman and they
actually if you read the comic book it's
actually pretty well done they show
every other superhero trying to defeat
this character doomsday and and this
thing that comes from space just starts
basically manhandling everybody and then
Superman's like away doing something
else and then finally he gets there and
he tries fighting and then he kills he's
being moody in his [__] Fortress of
Solitude no he had a chick with him he
had a chick with him good for him dude
he was trying to [__] figure
Lois Lane you guys Superman is just
banging some broad two deaths over from
work
he fell in love dude give the kid a
break listen
but here's the thing they don't man I
see could have any woman he wants
because I'm not a journalist who's gonna
[__] nitpick his [__] spelling and
punctuation it's not going to last but
here's the thing here's the thing she's
so cool why does he need a fortress a
Solitude why does he need this giant ice
bucket because she's a she's a woman he
gets it he [__] guesses
all right that's the big Advantage for
soup he's like Listen sweetheart when
I'm in the fortune softer I don't need
any calls zip it zip it sorry I was
saving the world last night I don't need
you right now and by the way I can see
you coming up through the walkway just
because you can't see me I can see you
so don't even try that [__] here's the
thing they had who'd they have at Batman
right they had Michael Keaton they had
Val Kilmer they had Christian Bale they
had I don't know George Clooney Ben
Affleck all this they've made Bronson
how many how many Spider-Mans have they
made Toby Maguire now this kid Thomas
the other kid Garfield all these
different kids and they've done two
Superman movies and the [__] stinks
like it was like they're not making that
movie because they say Marvel is better
than DC that's really what it is it's
more of a Marvel Studio thing and
Superman is not in the Marvel
umbrella but Superman a good Superman
movie has not been made dude for a long
long time but they've been making
Spider-Man and uh Spider-Man Marvel or
is he DC no he's Marvel
all right but Batman's DC right
yeah Batman is DC and they keep making
that one and they're not making more
Supermans
yeah that's [__] interesting it's the
same thing he's Bruce Wayne his parents
got murdered when he was young he has a
[__] mansion and he's got an English
butler and he [__] it's like okay
let me tell you something right now Paul
there's no I can't believe I'm having
this argument there is no [__] way
they will ever make a [__] Superman
movie as good as the one as that one
dude did with the dude
as good as that I know better villains
who the [__] well he's got that bald
[__] who looks like me Lex Luthor that's
his big [__] Nemesis a guy Bill's
right he's in space
yeah
yeah he goes optimistic clean I'm
supposed to be like what about that just
dude he's got the [__] Riddler he's
got the uh the show Pony I don't know
where they [__] fight whatever
no he's got he's got better [__] with
Spider-Man since the 1930s Paul no no no
there's just no rivalry Paul it's boring
well it's actually you know [__]
Spider Batman put up a pretty good fight
against them though in that one movie
where they just [__] I should have
brought my earplugs I thought it was
going to see AC DC it was so [__]
loud I actually tried Paul I'm like you
know what
as a comedian I should be knowing about
these [__] things
they're in the zeitgeist
um I'm gonna go to this thing it was
just all it was was loud
wait a minute dude but I don't I'm not
understanding why you not why you don't
like or you're giving credit to Superman
when like they didn't give him a good
movie dude why don't I probably because
you know what he's involved in yellow
journalism okay that's why I don't like
him he [__] coming after stand-up
comedians and he's ignoring all these
pharmaceutical companies he's ignoring
people who start never-ending [__]
words he's at the little [__] daily
plan dude oh Bill all he wanted to do
was Bank no The Daily Planet all he
wanted to do is bang Lois Lane that's
the only it was just it was just a fake
gig it was a fake gig he didn't want to
work there he was trying to build I
could get Lois Lane
I could pick Lois Lane up
I mean which lowest Lane we talking
all of them
was that Andrew's sister's haircut
she's a plain Jane Paul I'll tell you
right now Peter Parker's [__]
girlfriend that raven-haired [__]
goddamn chest and action yeah she went
crazy and started dating the other one
at least Lois Lane's gonna stay faithful
dude let me date the other one I'm
talking way back when she had the blue
highlights in her hair before they
turned her into that [__] whatever
they gave him build you would you date a
chick with blue highlights in her hair
Superman knows he's like I don't want
headaches Superman has blue highlights
in his hair no he doesn't he's got that
little he's got that little you know
cowlick yeah he's got he's got a little
I'm telling you dude holds him back he's
got that cow look he can't get his
Caesar's haircut I'm telling you right
now the right director the right
director whether it be JJ Abrams or
Nolan the right director gets a good
Superman script and that movie that they
need that and then I'm telling you Paul
it was like Lewis Hamilton all those
years when Mercedes just had the best
car and the best driver was a race to
the first turn you knew what the [__]
was gonna happen it just was like you
know the guy is like how is that not
Batman what you're describing you're
describing Batman they haven't even made
a Superman movie is my point
they have made Superman movies they
stink
they do and and and that's superheroes
yet simultaneously they can write all
these great movies for the other one the
character stinks Paul
I'll tell you the one they always [__]
up being an angry guy I hate what they
do to the Hulk
that he has to be all dumb because he's
mad it's like maybe you guys can't get
your [__] together and that's what's
making him so frustrated but he's
actually not dumb because he's a doctor
he's a son he's a he's a daughter turned
into a [__] anymore on the second he
starts yelling
[Music]
he's like all intellectual
dude that's so funny
that's so true you won't like me when
I'm angry yeah and he turns into that
[__] guy in your section where you're
actually excited that they threw him out
because you're like that guy could
actually hurt somebody but I guess he
can't be intellectual he can't be
intellectual ability he's throwing cars
through buildings
why they all do it
they all do it Superman doesn't do it he
destroyed his City with Batman but I
think we can all agree on something and
Bill Bill nailed it and I've been saying
it for a long time the Godfather of
superhero movies the greatest superhero
movie of all time is Heath Ledger as the
Joker and Christian Bale as Batman it's
number one it's incredible I can tell
you something I I couldn't give a [__]
about this any less
I just knew you liked Superman and I was
just trashing him I have no [__] idea
that's why no I'm not even trying
through my argument Paul I got Superman
work for the Daily Planet
he does
he doesn't no Peter Parker I was right
no Peter Parker works for the Daily
Planet no he works for uh Jameson Doug
Jameson from uh that Metal Show
Peter Parker's The Daily Bugle
Superman's uh that sounds like [__]
the Regal Beagle
um